PETE LePAGE: This calculator
might look familiar.
It's a demo web app from
the Polymer project.
With just a few changes to the
code-- like adding theme, color
and a meta tag, and adding
a manifest.json file--
I've made this web
app look and feel
like an installed native app.
Here's how I did it.
Let's start with theme color.
It gives you an easy way
to add a primary brand
color to your site or app, and
provides an extra visual pop
in the address bar
and tab switcher.
When your app has been
added to the home screen,
it also sets the
status bar color.
The syntax is pretty easy.
Add a meta tag to the
head element of each page,
with name equals theme
color, and set the content
to the color you want.
In the past, getting users to
add your web app to their home
screen has been a bit of a pain.
But in Chrome 42, we
introduced app install banners.
App install banners
allow your users
to quickly and seamlessly add
your web app to their home
screen with just a single tap.
In order for Chrome to show
the app install banner,
it looks for a manifest
file, a service worker,
and a set of other heuristics
about how often the user has
visited the site.
The manifest.json file
provides the browser
with details about
your application
that it might not be able
to get from elsewhere.
Like theme color,
every page needs
to include a link element
with rel equals manifest,
and an href pointing to
the manifest.json file.
Inside the manifest,
I've defined short name,
which is used in
space-constrained locations
such as the app name under
the icon on the home screen.
But the full app name may
be used in other locations.
To make sure your
icons look their best,
Chrome first looks
for a 48-dip image.
Remember, dips are
device-independent pixels.
So on a 2x display, it's
going to try and use
a 96x96 pixel image, or
a 144x144 pixel image
for a 3x display.
If it can't find one of those,
it will use the closest match.
For the paper calculator,
I've created four icons.
A 1x at 48 pixels, a 2x at 96
pixels, a 3x at 144 pixels,
and a 4x at 192 pixels.
I've specified the icon source,
the size, and the MIME type
for each.
Adding the start URL
parameter is helpful,
since it tells Chrome
which page to load
when the app is initialized.
It also has the added
benefit of stat tracking.
By pointing this to
a unique page that
uses Google Analytics,
we can track
how many users are opening this
app from their home screen.
This also means that your
manifest can span many files,
but always start
with the same URL.
By setting display:standalone,
Chrome hides the address bar
on launch.
Let's see what happens
when we open the site.
There's my blue theme color
applied to the address bar,
and the app install
banner shows up.
Simple as that.
PUPPET: OK, hold on a sec.
Time out.
He glossed over some things
that need to happen for app
install banners to appear.
He mentioned earlier
that Chrome looks
for several heuristics, the
manifest and a service worker.
Chrome will then show
the app install banner
if the user visits the app
on at least two separate days
over a period of two weeks.
Without those, the app install
banner will not appear.
For this video, I've used
a little puppet magic
and added a simple
service worker.
For testing, I've enabled the
bypass app banner engagement
checks flag.
Say that one 10 times fast.
What that does is
bypass the checks
on how many visits are
required before the app install
banner is shown.
PETE LePAGE: Woah,
that was weird.
Feels like I was frozen in
time there for a second.
As I said, there's
the theme color
applied to the address bar.
But I also get the app
install banner appearing
at the bottom of the
screen, prompting
me to add the calculator
to my home screen.
Let's click Add and
see what happens.
Yep, there it is.
Notice it used short name
we defined in the manifest,
and the correct icon specified
in the manifest file.
Sweet.
When I click on the app, it
loads as a standalone app.
There's no address
bar, the status bar
is the color we
expect, and our app
feels like an
installed native app.
And remember, I cheated
with my service worker.
This calculator doesn't
really work offline
because the service
worker doesn't
provide an offline experience.
But you could that with
just a little bit more work.
So there you have it.
I've shown you how you can
use theme color, the manifest,
and service workers to
make your app feel more
like an installed native app.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Pete LePage, and I/O out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]